Este de aquí es Walter Bayer
y es la opción que ha escogido la izquierda
Europea como speedzen
candidato candidato principal
para las elecciones europeas,
es decir,
su candidato para que lidere la Comisión Europea.
El político es ahora el Presidente del partido,
pero es casi 1 desconocido para la política europea
ya que no es eurodiputado
ni lo será cuando acaben las elecciones.
Desde el aeropuerto para irme de vuelta a Bruselas
os cuento que esta elección,
la de escoger a Walter Bayer como candidato principal,
se parece 1 poco a la elección
que Han hecho los socialdemócratas
que Han escogido a Nicolas Smith
como su candidato principal,
que es también 1 persona con bajo perfil político.
Y seguramente
esta decisión se ve influenciada
porque la Comisión Europea ya tiene 1 Gran favorita,
la actual Presidente de la Comisión Europea,
Ursula fonderlayen,
que ya ha anunciado
que quiere volver a repetir en el cargo
y es sin duda la Gran favorita